I had never really played music growing
up very much so I mean I played a little
short stint of piano as a child set some
basic sort of notes and chords and
things like that some basic information
but it was very short
it was between moves and my family and
so I didn't play for very long but I had
some basic information and I always just
really liked liked music a lot so all
growing up I just listened to music all
the time I started with probably when I
started with Michael Jackson and all
that kind of stuff that you would listen
to growing up in the 80s but then I
remember I think I picked up new order
on 1997 it was substance and that
changed my world I was just like
listening to in a car somewhere and I
ran out and bought it and then got
really into sort of alternative music
from an early age and began listening to
that so I've always been very music
obsessed and for most of the periods of
my life from working really hard at work
I have like an album that's very
connected to it so finishing my PhD was
like Nine Inch Nails pretty hate machine
there's always just like an album that
was playing that's centered around my
life centered around work I mean soul
coughing what was there well so there
was a actually I'm gonna forget the
names of soul coughing albums but
there's a lot of soul coughing that
happened through a lot of my tests in
college and there was Bush we know this
the one with glycerine and all that
sixteen stone that I think was during
another period of like hard work there
was yeah well so this music always
there's like Radiohead and all those
kinds of different bands and a lot of
real lesser-known and like indie rock
bands like now probably jealous sound
and Frightened Rabbit which will
probably be very well known soon they're
rock my world and helped me through a
grant application I mean so like I think
it's like each grant application I could
kind of go through it and you know make
a little journal but it's like each kind
of major application or test Fisher
Spooner for my boards medical school
boards so yeah so a lot of albums and I
just uh but I was listening to music and
I don't know if that was my obsession
and so that's a
my obsession with music but so I always
like music but I never really I just
considered it something that I spectate
like I did sports I did you know school
activities like leadership activities I
did school and that's what you do and
then I just listen to music and it
wasn't until graduate school where I had
two friends Taylor Antrim and Bruce
Hickey who were also Americans studying
at Oxford and they would always talk
about like they both played guitar they
both loved we love the same music we
listen to the same music - Mouse and
always we're talking about these
different bands we loved and you know
and I'd always and they always talked
about starting a band a kind of fantasy
band all the time and I was like stop
fantasy banding just start a band like
you know now that was as good a time as
any
and they said well we at least need a
rhythm section I didn't really know what
that meant at that point I was like well
what is that you know I knew drums I
guess and they're like well we at least
need a bassist and so that next day
Bruce and I went out and bought a bass
guitar then we started a band and we
just started writing right away we never
did any covers because I think we would
have made the cover sound so bad that we
just did only original stuff that we in
this like spare short period we just
gigged out all the time like around
Oxford and stuff and went crazy with it
yeah I'm still playing I've been playing
him since so that would that would have
been like 1997 so been playing for a
decade probably on and off but I started
I joined a band in medical school that
I've been with ever since
it's probably a relief I can't really
say it's integrated I think I mean I
don't really want it to be integrated I
think it'd be bad if it was sort of like
I think it's it's it's a different thing
it comes together I definitely get a
sense that when I'm most creative
scientifically is when I start like I
told one of my graduate students
recently cuz I was you know thinking
about all these projects and developing
projects and reading a lot
scientifically and trying to explore new
areas and I told her that I had realized
that I was actually in a good place when
like three songs just spit out out of
nowhere and I you know my I can tell my
brain is like in one of those active
creative places when random like
melodies pop out so